Oshin just came out yeah now you said I
don't to paraphrase but you're kind of
saying this is back to the core of Lady
Antebellum yeah the sound of it for sure
I mean we really went back to much more
of that organic sound of the first two
records I think naturally as we toured
and we started playing much bigger
venues you know we felt like we needed
to get some songs like bartender
downtown yeah you look good and we loved
that side of our of our catalogue but if
we had to narrow it down like what songs
really define us when we leave this
earth it would be something's like need
you now or you know last thing well what
if I never get over you you know and so
we really want to get back to that
warmth and and it seems like the fans
are kind of missing that from us
[Music]
[Applause]
at this age we're digging deep and being
vulnerable and just trying to tell our
stories as honestly as we can so there's
definitely a material on here that I
don't think we could have made ten years
ago
[Music]
beautiful neuter happening yes so is it
different now with kids do tour
differently they come out of a lot you
know we're really fortunate I will say
we all you know are able to have our own
you know family bus and bring the kids
out when we want to but we also you know
don't want to disrupt their lives too
much so a lot of times they stay home
but we've definitely as we've moved
forward wanted to make sure that you
know we're not just putting the career
ahead of our family so we definitely
don't go as hard on the road as we used
to but when we go we're very intentional
with it like this tour I mean we're
doing a full big tour summer you know
all summer long and and you know I just
think where we learn how to kind of
balance it a lot a lot more now
[Music]
[Music]
feel really torn you know every time I
leave the house but I also really love
what I do and I know that it's a part of
a huge part of why a band put on this
earth and so you know as a mom wanting
to show my daughters that you can do
both and that doesn't mean that both
don't sacrificing things at certain
points but when you love the people you
work with and you love your family and
you want to get you know I want to
provide them not only with a great
livelihood but also show them that you
can you can achieve your dream chase
after what you're called to do and have
a family I mean there's cool
inclinations with the kids all yeah
definitely we just recently moved in our
piano was getting repaired and just got
delivered today back after being in our
house over a month and Isley hasn't been
able to play and she was playing
non-stop today just so happy to have it
back and but yeah I mean all of our kids
I think are are getting it honest I just
got mines got a drum set and it is it's
like why did I do that yes so little boy
I mean there's no doubt that he's going
to teach them how to play guitar at some
point it's like so we might we might
have to have us a little little
you
[Music]